jacques chirac au chevet de la
francophonie l'état brazzaville pour le
congrès de l'association des maires
francophones une manière de prélude au
sommet des nations qui parlent français
qui est prévue pour le mois de septembre
prochain au québec au canada elle
jean-louis les scènes officiellement
jacques chirac est venu ici en tant que
maire de paris puisque c'est à ce titre
qu'il est président de l'association
internationale des maires francophones
une association qui regroupe 42 membres
représentant 28 pays officiellement
jacques chirac a donc planché sur le
thème imposé
les moyens de la modernisation de
l'administration publique vaste sujet
mais ce déplacement offre surtout
l'avantagé au premier ministre de lui
permettre de rencontrer beaucoup de
responsables africains dans un vieux il
leur a même ce matin proposer une devise
coopération amitié francophonie autre
intérêt pour jacques chirac au cours de
ce voyage la rencontre avec le président
congolais monsieur sassou n'guesso qui
jusqu'à la semaine prochaine et le
président en exercice de l'ua
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
au cours des discussions en tête à tête
deux hommes ont abordé le problème du
tchad celui de l'afrique du sud est bien
sûr la dette africaine rencontre
d'autant plus importante que l'homme
fort de la république populaire du congo
jouit d'une audience certaine dans les
autres pays du continent président du
parti congolais du travail président de
la république président du gouvernement
monsieur n'guesso juifs ne connaît pas
de problèmes de cohabitation l'aide